[Music]
thank you for joining us my name is
Anita keepin Gucci and I'm a product
marketing manager for data and analytics
and I'm part of the Google cloud
platform group and today we have a
really exciting panel I'll just do a
quick introduction I have Jordan here he
is an engineering director for GCT and
then we have Sudhir he's a director
product management for GCP and then we
have Matt who's the research director
data platforms and analytics for 4-5-1
research welcome gentlemen
so would like to make this session
interactive so we have a couple mics
here in the room if you have any
questions or any comments then just feel
free to step up and get on the mic and
then we'll give you a podium okay so
let's get started so we know that data
is becoming one of the most valuable
assets for an organization it's not
surprising because I feel like it's one
of the things you've probably heard over
and over again at this conference and
you've also heard this term that says
data is the new oil so let's start with
you Matt how would you interpret this
statement and how should customers think
about their data and also a data
analytics in this environment sure
thanks Newton thank you everyone for
coming to this session just to give you
a bit of background so I'm mad as I'm
the research director data platforms now
analytics of 4-5-1 research we're an
industry analyst firm covering the
entire industry but the channel as we
call it I look after covers everything
from back-end data platforms through to
front-end analytics and machine learning
and AI and there's a team of us doing
that but I'm responsible for the overall
coverage so obviously you know data and
the value of data is something we've
been looking at for you know a number of
years I think it's you know it's
interesting when we talk about companies
suddenly sort of discovering the value
of data obviously you know this has been
happening for thousands of years
companies hopefully have been making
decisions based on data but I think what
we see is changing is you know I'm not
convinced by Davis the new old let's not
get into that but definitely what
dueces that companies and wanting to
become more data-driven and we could say
like data is definitely the fuel for
innovation within organizations and
particularly we're going for the
buzzwords chucking digital
transformation as well as companies are
looking to transform become more
responsive to their customers they see
that data and analytics is the fuel that
enables them to do that and you know
there's various aspects in which ways
which organizations can can take
advantage of that when we're getting to
those in more detail so perhaps for now
I'll stop there and let you come in on
they chose the new oil law no I agree I
think as we talk to more and more
customers they all want to be more
data-driven have a data-driven culture
and have tools that are easy to go ahead
and leverage this data in day-to-day
decision-making and I think that's the
key thing that that I hear all the time
from from customers that is so true one
thing that it's also really key that you
have data that you can trust so if your
data is not trustworthy and you're
trying to make decisions based on it
you're gonna make terrible decisions and
so sometimes we see like you know
there's not a data cleaning process or
people just don't really understand the
data well enough and and that you know
if you don't understand your data well
enough then then you know you're you're
gonna use it poorly yeah couldn't agree
more so we know that consumerization is
one of the key drivers for growth and
data and when I say consumerization you
can think about it I mean the number of
videos that people are actually
recording just have recorded so far
aren't are continuing to record right I
mean if you think about just the amount
of social media posts the amounts I mean
the connected homes right within and out
of things and I think IDC has an
interesting statistics and I think you
mentioned the sudhir yesterday I think
they're looking at a hundred and
sixty-three zettabytes of data by 2025 I
mean if you ask me I I can't even
imagine how much data that is right or
even just to think about it so Matt in
your research just curious what our
customers looking for in a data
analytics product which is this amount
of growth and
yeah well I think it's actually multiple
thing I mean clearly the volume of data
is significant absolutely and and and
also she mentioned you know data coming
from new sources or actually
organizations taking advantage of data
that they already had but perhaps it
wasn't economically viable to storm
process before hence we saw you know the
vengeance of Hadoop and no sequel but
then cloud storage as well to deal with
that and then obviously IOT is
generating you know even more data but
there are other aspects to it as well I
mean we see a lot of organizations been
a lot of talk with us couple it's about
democratization of data or at least
self-service access to data putting data
in the hands of you know more business
users and decision makers and that is
all tied in with you know this thing
it's about being data-driven getting
data and analytics into the heart of the
business not just for a select few than
the organization who make decisions so
in terms of what organizations are
looking for all of that but as cheaply
as possible and as flexible as possible
so there's there's multiple things and
there's what I think is you know it
clearly is there's there's a huge range
of different products and services that
organizations can use for different
purposes and it's all then you're
getting to the nuances of the
application and I think that's something
you know because there's been so much
innovation technology in this space in
the last few years sometimes it's you
know it's easy to forget you have to
start with the business case what are
you trying to achieve and then figure
out which technology can help you
deliver on that yeah good point
just one more thing to add here right
the lot of customers when they look at
that number like 163
it's like massive number and a lot of
times what they think about is but my
data is not that big today the thing
that that customers need is scalable
platforms that can scale to what
datasets they have today but also
ability to scale over a period of time
when the data grows one of the things we
are noticing with all the customers that
have been using for example bigquery for
a while is as they start see value in
data they collect more and more I think
traditional data warehouses have this
problem where they all teach people to
cleanse reduce aggregate store
the whole idea is how do you not get as
more data it's like you reduce your cost
by aggregating pre aggregating cleansing
and all of that versus what cloud
platforms allow you to do is collect
first and then analyze figure out what's
valuable and that's where actually the
real value comes in we have customers
that have literally had 100x growth in
real-time data they were collecting from
from just within a year to 18 months
just because they were started getting
value out of what of the data sets that
they started collecting so I would say
from a product perspective focusing on
not just what you need today but there
are a lot of things that on from Isis
systems restrict you from as you think
about cloud it is the scalable
infrastructure that's there so look at
how you can leverage data in a different
way
bet on like scalable platforms that will
allow you to go ahead and analyze
maximum amount of data that you can
collect and so this question is for you
Jordan which i think is very interesting
given you know the massive amounts of
data and then also given what we're
investing in how can you explain how GCP
is thinking about data analytics and
this innovation it'd be interesting to
just give the audience a little bit of a
preview into just the span of products
we have to help with data analytics sure
well I think one of the things we want
to do is we don't want to be sort of
just another another cloud particularly
with regard to data analytics we have
some of the best infrastructure some of
the best technology in in the world and
we want to really continue to to
innovate and not just sort of arrest on
rest on our laurels so you know Sudhir
is alluding to like we don't want to
sort of just be a data warehouse we want
to be an amazing data warehouse but we
also want to sort of push the boundaries
like what's what format is your data in
as your data is you know all large data
sets are generally streaming data sets
so how do we process the data in in in a
natural streaming format and I think
Google has been a good thought leader in
in streaming systems and so how do we
kind of drive on that also how do we
take our our advantages in
infrastructure and kind of apply those
to things that nobody else can do to
give it a good example of that you know
one of the things we announced yesterday
was the geospatial feed
in bigquery and so okay you know
Postgres has some geospatial features
one of the things that this is gonna be
enable you to do is getting able you to
join a billion data points in one table
with a billion data points in another
two table table to find the points that
are like within a certain radius of each
other that's a cross join of a billion
by a billion points like really nobody
can do that except except Google and we
want to sort of continue to apply those
kinds of those kinds of technologies and
those kinds of like smarts to to the
things that we're building yeah
absolutely to add one more thing to that
the other side we are very focused on
also is just simplifying the the use of
these kind of tools that we are building
one is scaling is super important but
ease of use is really important for us
some of the capabilities that we
announced in this in this week one of
them was actually ability to directly
the new bigquery UI it's snappy and all
of that but the most interesting thing
there is you can now run that query that
Jordan was talking about with a
one-click you can actually transfer that
into a data studio visualization tool
and actually visualize it explore it and
then create a report out of it
just with one click the other thing you
can do is with sheets integration that
we announced you can go in sheets use a
bigquery connector fire a similar kind
of query move the data into sheets and
then just use that experience that all
your users are already familiar with to
analyze that kind of data visualize it
so ease of use is another side of things
which is super important for customers
that we focus on yeah and if you want to
learn more about bigquery we actually
have a showcase in Moscone South and I'm
actually going to be there Manning the
boot from 12:30 to about 3 o'clock so we
actually are showcasing the new UI so
just a shameless plug there but so thank
you so much so we're going to switch
gears just a little bit one of the
things that we keep hearing from a lot
of our customers is this idea of
adopting a multi cloud strategy right
the fact that no longer our customers
just using one cloud but pretty much
multiple clouds for different workloads
for different reasons right and what I'd
love to hear from you Matt's in your
research what are you seeing happen
the industry and what do you think is
driving this adoption
yeah Emily's definitely real and
definitely happening what's interesting
if you said you know what's driving the
adoption initially so we see so among
surveying our user base it's something
like 60 percent of cloud adopters are
using multiple clouds a lot of them have
ended up using multi clouds completely
by accident because they've got
different groups in the organization
that have used different clouds for
different purposes shadow whitey just
spun out and she stumbled into this
world of having multiple clouds and
that's you know not something that you
know isn't necessarily sort of viable in
the long term so what we see
increasingly as organizations doing is I
mean hybrid cloud is a term that's used
by different people for different
reasons we use that to talk about
companies actually strategically
deliberately using multiple clouds
specifically to support a single
application or workload and so what we
see is increasingly organizations are
deliberately doing that actually of that
sort of sixty percent who are using
multiple clouds about 70 percent are
either already using multiple clouds to
deliver a single application or are
considering or working towards that and
so increasingly you know as I say you
know that's it's just going to be the
norm and it's it's then about not you
know comparing different cloud providers
a very high level you know very
strategically looking at different
technologies individually and how you
can combine them to to deliver you know
a better better complete a complete
whole I mean a great example of that
would be you know existing applications
they're already running up there in one
cloud but I know you want to take
advantage of you know some vision
analysis machine learning or speech
analysis machine learning and it could
be a service on another cloud it's the
best choice for that so you know call
out to that for that very specific
purpose to deliver that combined entity
so we see many many organizations are
increasingly you know strategically
deliberately looking to do that as
opposed to just sort of stumbling into
their the case of having multiple clouds
yeah good point anything you want to add
Sudhir yeah so the other thing is a
multi cloud is one and we fundamentally
believe most of the investments
today four customers are on premises and
so having in this hybrid scenario where
most customers will be in a multi cloud
or on promises and cloud pattern so this
is why if you looked at the the keynotes
the first two days the focus on being an
open cloud and ability for you to run
your workloads in multiple clouds
enabling that kind of capability is
super important for us the ability to
run your SPARC workloads whether you're
running on promises in cloud with beam
what we're doing having the same code
that can run with dataflow but also run
with spark or flink super important for
us so we were focusing a lot on
standardization supporting standard
sequel is part of that whole initiative
for us super important and also composer
which is airflow we're taking open
source technology making it available
for customers to use and you can use
airflow or composer now to go ahead and
have orchestration that can span across
clouds on promises all of that and you
can centrally manage it so so yes the
open cloud initiative is key driver
because of the requirement that
customers have that spans across
multiple thousand and that's oh yeah
absolutely and then from like a workload
perspective what are you seeing
customers sort of like keep on prances
like on the cloud is your a difference
every customer is different people are
going to choose what best technologies
that that they need for their scenarios
what I am noticing is the from a Google
cloud perspective data analytics machine
learning is our key differentiator and
we see lot of times customer first try
out those services on Google and then
they go adopt other areas and stuff like
that so so I do see a lot of customers
starting with data analytics on one
cloud they do have different workloads
that run in different places lot of
people run their operational systems on
promises maybe in other clouds but for
analytics machine learning I think we
have highly differentiated services I
think these things yeah absolutely yeah
I think I mean one of the things we're
increasingly saying obviously as you
said you know the vast majority of
workloads still run on premises
particularly data
analytics workloads but what we've seen
you know in our in the in the surveys
that we do is you know we look at which
of the most popular applications or
workloads in the cloud obviously
database and analytics are widely
popular applications so they were always
there or there abouts but they were
always you know somewhat further down
the list in the in the last couple of
years they've been increasing and and
now I think the last one we did at the
start this year databases was number one
analytics was number two as you would
expect given the you know the the the
the wide adoption of those workplace but
it does speak to that I think the
maturity the increasing maturity of
adoption in relation to the to the cloud
but but you're right the key point is
you know there are a huge amount of
workloads that will either remain
on-premises or will be you know we tend
to think about lifting and shifting
workloads to the cloud actually most of
the time that doesn't happen it's about
refactoring or redesigning the
applications for the new new version of
that running in the cloud in a modern
architecture taking advantage of newer
capabilities so we see a lot more of
that going on and and so in in some ways
it will take a long time for the some of
the changes to pick up become obvious
because a lot of those workloads will
continue on premises and slowly be
retired and so yeah the shift is it you
know it's a fundamental shift but it's
actually happening in some cases
relatively slowly yeah anything yeah of
course graduating just in terms of like
you know you mentioned that lift and
shift is not necessarily something that
people are doing they're not starting
with I think what we often see is people
have a problem and that problem may may
not be their central data warehousing or
database team but it may just be a team
that is not getting the numbers they
want fast enough and so they pull that
into the cloud and then people start
seeing hey well we get these amazing
amazing numbers super quickly and they
start coding like it's like a thread in
a sweater that just sort of pulls more
and more more and more into it then
eventually the you know the data
warehousing team is like hey you know we
can all our data is there already why
don't we just you know move our move the
rest of our workloads yeah absolutely
and I think one of the the things you
gentlemen have mentioned earlier was
just this idea again of just the massive
amounts of data and such to make sense
that you know for organizations it's
easier to have all
data in one place and then to start to
do analytics right and so that's
definitely another push just one more
thing just in that same realm so this is
exactly why from a product perspective
we have invested in data transfer
service so if you think about it lot of
customers spend a lot of money with
Google on advertising and different
things and our thing was this is a
completely different audience it's not a
warehousing audience but it is the
marketing analysts that need to go ahead
and analyze their spend optimize their
spend how do you do better for a
marketing analytics and so fit there we
basically launched data transfer service
was like hey if it's few clicks you can
get your AdWords data double-click data
all of this data into into bigquery and
you can analyze it we have seen amazing
amount of adoption for this customers
who are not traditionally GCP customers
knowing this they're like ok let me with
few clicks pull data and start analyzing
it visualizing it they're creating these
reports in data studio sharing it across
the organization and suddenly use jardín
was saying you get this whole community
started forming in in organizations that
started using it and then that pulls
through the whole thing so great again
guys we have a couple mics so if you
have any questions or if you have any
comments just feel free to come to one
of the mics
okay so we'll switch gears again just a
little bit I think one of the things
that I've heard in this conference over
and over again is this idea of just open
source and open source architecture
right and just Sudhir quickly what are
you hearing from our customers about
open source technologies and how are
they appreciating what a Google cloud is
doing yeah I think open source is super
critical as I talk to customers this
ability just because of hybrid and multi
cloud scenarios ability for them to run
their workloads across and having that
option of running them anywhere else is
super important to them this way as I
was saying our investment in Bheem is so
important for our customers is like when
they they love data flow like once
customers come start leveraging data
flow for large-scale data processing I
hope they never go away but that option
always exists is here with Bheem being
open source and runners being available
in different engines they can actually
do that so that's
super important for them resonates
really well with CIOs and all now
similarly as I was saying a lot of
customers already have huge deployments
of Hadoop spark on-premises
airflow air flow is amazing composer
it's very fascinating for me composer in
its private beta or private alpha we had
it was like yeah thousand customers I
have no idea how products get to
thousand customers with being a private
but it was because air flow which is
like the orchestration tool Apache
project everybody loved it already so we
just enable that on the platform and
that option was crazy so it's just
supporting open source being an open
cloud
enabling experiences that can come from
those is super important for yeah and
composer g8 is that correct yeah we
launched composite Aegean also yeah
would love to hear your thoughts Matt on
just open source and open source
technology yeah no absolutely I actually
I'm so I joined four five one research
about ten and a bit years ago you can
remember back that far and actually that
time we had an open source practice
because open source was relatively new
and different and a lot of companies
were still trying to figure out what it
meant and so we would work with clients
both on the enterprise side and the
vendor side to us to help them figure
that out obviously over time it became
more normalized than it's just part of
everything we do but what's been
fascinating is you know over that time
to see the the the approach to open
source change I mean people just say you
won't get fired for buying IBM
definitely now it's you wouldn't get
fired for buying open source you know
it's that insurance policy that their
organizations have and most of the you
know engagement we did with the clients
and they're looking at different
products and vendors you know it's
definitely it's not always a deal
breaker but it's always there in the mix
like where they would default to open if
they can and I'd actually had a
conversation with a Google cloud
customer the other day here which proved
the value of that I can't say it was but
very happy Google cloud customer but for
one reason or another their stack driver
cost suddenly went absolutely through
the roof that's what they decided to do
was just
a brief period while they figure out
what's going on stop that
switch to open source obviously they had
the skills to be able to do this yeah
but they could do that they could just
switch to open source do it themselves
because it's open source it's that you
know it's it's it's a one-off thing that
probably go back using the hosted
version but it just was you know that
that benefit that gives people the
choice to to chain a lady how they
deploy and manage that depending on you
know what whatever happens in the future
and it's a little bit you know insurance
policy basically
[Music]